citizens of the reject Nation we are
here for the penultimate episode of The
Last of Us season one I'm not prepared
but I'm so excited joining me once again
in the hot seat is Tara Erickson Tara
how you doing today I'm good guys I got
a cool t-shirt on yeah roller skate Club
sound off in the comments for Tara's
drip in fact leave a like for Tara's
drip and why don't you go ahead before
you do anything else subscribe and ring
that Bell
ring the bell oh we need a super
and I'm glad that you're getting your
flowers for that as well check out La
eats and drinks which is Tara's brand
new food experience on the web for you
guys eating and drinking my way through
Los Angeles and recording at all oh
that's right don't miss a single moment
get those tasty morsels we appreciate
you guys for not spoiling this
experience for us if you want to get the
full-on gamer perspective go and check
out Greg and Andrew's Last of Us
reactions and as well if you want to
enjoy all of our reactions uncut with
everything that doesn't make these
highlight reels come on over to
patreon.com the real rejects where you
can sync up with your own copy enjoy the
full experience and uh last but not
least guys uh we got a new Last of Us
inspired t-shirt the Greg and the Zero
edition team put together and if you
want one they're available now in the
real rejects shopzeroedition.com store
got beanies and hoodies and all sorts of
fun stuff over there Tara did I forget
anything is there anything you want to
tell the people no except I would like
that t-shirt all right well you're an
extra large now here we go
foreign
[Music]
you get this song down yet John I'm
working on it it's it's actually not as
complicated as you would imagine it's
just about getting the mood and the
timing right so maybe by the finale
episode I'll have a little some some for
you guys yeah you better have a Vibe
going on because if I'm gonna wear all
yellow
you know to try to virus it up do that
terrafungus yeah
God now I have to go buy all yellow
clothing just glue some buttered lettuce
to your face I really dug my own grave
Revelation 21
and I saw a new Heaven and a new Earth
it's Los Angeles this week and I heard a
great voice out of Heaven saying behold
the Tabernacle of God
Church in a steakhouse I do not mind
that
from their eyes
what God get in there yeah where's the
get in there guys tears coming down
they're not being wiped
he shall provide
and God will wipe away all tears from
their eyes
neither will there be any more pain do
you know what that means
there's a pop quiz coming up are you
sure
oh the ground is too cold to dig
we'll bury your father in the spring
oh stank the cutlets of Christ finally
busts out the stake at least here in
winter like his body will be perfectly
preserved until the spring true is it
probably like an ice cube out there how
much do we have left
the hotel on rations
maybe a week
two at best
uh I sensed doubt in there
you haven't lost faith in you David
you're just scared not from them
from you I still believe it's been uh
last six months have been hurt
but I need to know you're with me
believe better now go get our guns we're
going hunting
foreign
falls in the pile of guns they all go
off
and uh feel free to Enlighten and or
roast us for that buddy boy casting
there
[Music]
oh
wake him up with some jerky smell a
jerky always gets me up in the morning
put it right under his nose
[Music]
gonna try to go hunt now is she going to
run into those people out there I saw
her look okay yeah we see you
wow dang the apocalypse seems so
peaceful when you're not being attacked
by butter lettuce heads
[Music]
but it's so cute that you just keep it
as a pet oh oh Ellie okay
frostbite God that would hurt so bad
oh okay now that's a prize
oh you got this come on you got it girl
kill shot please oh no no no kill him no
I hate it I hate it no
[Music]
take her thing she already started on it
feel it God sent us this wounded deer
the venison of Christ
little senior
yeah you think we can just take it
quickly whoever shot it's probably
nearby
damn
oh heck yeah
now
yeah yeah girl get it
now help me carry this back to Joel and
he sudden moves that put one right
between your eyes did all for buddy boy
my name is David
this is my friend James
we're from a larger group women children
and we're all very very hungry I'm from
a large group too
also hungry not with biblical names what
do you need we have boots medicine
back in our village here buddy boy can
go get it
talked to Howard he's got a case with
some penicillin
bring back two bottles and a syringe
it's not code James as I said
come on man come on man you're gonna get
half the deerless good scoot buddy boy
yeah buddy boy buddy man he's like well
in John chapter five
yeah we gotta really King here in the
situation
with your dad's gun
you the one that's sick
that's why you're out here on your own
smart it's a Four Mile round trip back
to our settlement it's gonna be a while
before James gets back we should
take shelter bring him with us
oh boy
oh jeez
I'm just glad he's dead and not in pain
you're the leader yes
some weird cult thing well you sort of
kind of got me there I am a preacher but
just pretty standard bible stuff prefer
the term congregation and as we wandered
we picked up new people along the way
until we ended up here
oh you look how to run out sooner or
later
I believe everything happens for a
reason so I sent four of our people to a
nearby town to to scavenge what they
could only three of them came back and
the one that didn't was a father he had
a daughter just like you
and her dad was taken from her but we
were able to eat him he was murdered
by this crazy man that crazy man
was traveling with a little girl
oh no
everything happens for a reason
oh James lower the gun
whoa dude so weird dicey oh my
goodness
did you bring the medicine
yeah but throw it to her
David
you want to eat or you want to get
Vengeance I would rather eat
back away
you won't survive for long out there I
can protect you
get that whole deer though dang it yeah
so you're just gonna let it get away
oh I have a feeling he has a different
plan in mind Let Jesus Take the Wheel
he'll he'll find some fitting
retribution for this
Joe where the do I put this
oh good right little thing I think it's
like in the arms okay
okay
I hope you got the dosage right as well
I have some liver and onions tonight
yum yum
what is it
again
dude can you find us like an elk or
something yes we found a girl who was
with the man who took Alex from us
when the Sun rises I'll lead a group out
to pick up her Trail won't be hard to
find in the snow
and we'll bring that man to justice of
course you will
kill both of them
oh
okay nope nope
back to layers
like what's this guy's deal
okay it's way too reasonable up front
it's a bit culty now I know you think
you don't have a father anymore
but the truth is Hannah you will always
have a father and you will show him
respect when he's speaking
it's everyone's Daddy
oh yeah who'd you lose who are you
trying to fill a void with all these
people with he lost his Steakhouse man
[Music]
the sound design in this scene a lot of
people in a studio just think clanking
props to the Foley team
[Music]
killing an Ellie becoming RN
oh
two-horse garage
I'm gonna go and cover your truck oh no
uh
oh
Darcy
is that a bird of prey
symbolism hmm
birds of death
shite now you know kid
yep
good good good this man's not already
dead he's dangerous about the girl if we
leave her out here she'll die
yeah maybe that's God's will
talk to me about cat's will I decide
God's will keep your mouth shut buddy
boy
[Laughter]
Ellie you're gonna have to like do some
oh
[Music]
did anybody makes it down here you can
kill them you got it
what an interesting presence for him
this episode
oh man
oh bad feeling bad feeling I'm so scared
right now
uh the anxiety
oh
okay no no don't shoot the horse or her
okay alive
[Music]
oh boy
yes Ride Like the Wind
if you want him come and claim him God
please don't be a good shot buddy boy no
no oh no no the Horrors
I don't like it
are they gonna eat that horse now they
better
[Music]
what
father says no you all got some Penance
to do now two of you with me drag the
horse
the rest of you stay here go door to
door
start knocking you so hungry from
vengeance
deliver it it's a cult it's a cult cult
[Music]
that's right
wake up come on get up
hope you're good at knife throwing or
playing dead
yes
oh my God
I'm still so worried
[Music]
I have teeth
[Laughter]
oh
no thank you
I started worrying you wouldn't wake up
why am I in a cage you're a dangerous
person you've certainly proven that
you can't survive on your own no one can
I'm not on my own that part of your life
it's ending
and what I'm offering you is a beginning
but if you can't find a way to trust me
then yes you are alone
only I can help you
have to remember Ellie he owned a
steakhouse that's right that's right
trust the Outback man
trust Ruth's Chris over here
[Music]
the Beards on this crew are amazing oh
[Laughter]
yes that was nice bait good job Joel he
carried him all the way out there up the
stairs leave him alone oh you're next
please I don't know any girl
yeah
I can't help you you focused
where
ah the town
Silver Lake
this is Silver Lake I think so I live
there not for long it's a resort a
resort
Where We Are
the resort is oh that's great
if he's actually going to spot your
buddy points too
oh man go ask him he'll tell you I'm not
lying
oh
[Music]
you you I ain't telling you
it's okay no I believe him no
wow
whoa cold but also a full effective hand
killer that was that was hard
don't trust the food
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
I'd rather not
if you want to judge me judge you
[Music]
[Laughter]
so what was I supposed to do
let them starve yeah maybe you don't
believe that
I don't think your friend would either
didn't he take another man's life to
save yours he was defending himself keep
Joel's name out of your mouth yeah you
see a lot so do I
and you know what I see when I look at
you
me
you have a violent heart
and I should know
because I do too I've always had a
violent heart but then the world ended
and I was shown the truth
now my cordyceps
sure it feeds and protects its children
and it secures its future with violence
if it must
that's true why are you telling me all
of this
I'm a Shepherd surrounded by sheep and
all I want
is an equal
[Laughter]
what about my friend
I can tell the others to stop looking
for him
they'll spare him
if he leaves us in peace they will just
let him go
they do what I tell them to do
they follow me yeah for how long though
too late they're already dead buddy do
you think of what we could do together
we'd make this place perfect
imagine the life we could give them
Joel just needs to come in now be my
daughter wife
no what no no no no
no no
hahaha
you look Ed always
no dang it ugh Ally what tell them that
Ellie is a little girl who broke here
yes
how did you put it
tiny little pieces oh wow
see you at the steakhouse
[Music]
buddy
oh God gotta find grogu man come on ding
Jaren
[Music]
it's good survival horror
oh the horse right
no
oh yeah oh yeah
yup yup yup
oh God neat freezers open okay all right
ugh
oh geez
shut up
oh whoa
[Music]
you had your chance
oh no and no sorry
sorry roll up my sleeve look at it
oh
of course
what did you say
[Music]
there's a reason
oh now she will return by now this isn't
real that looks pretty she's still
transmit
[Music]
no Jesus
oh
oh man oh my goodness where is everybody
not that I'm complaining
foreign
sorry buddy boy we're eating good
tonight
it's the cult
[Music]
oh
they're busy preparing some Kool-Aid
yeah either stay Save The Steakhouse or
go kill Ellie save the steakhouse yeah
No Way Out Ellie the doors are locked
and I have the keys
Ellie
you better save your Steakhouse buddy
come on how are you gonna cook up all
those dead bodies I know
think of the mouths to feed what's the
secret
or are you just that
special yep she is
no one likes being humiliated Ellie you
don't know how good I am what you don't
know what I could have given you
just let me oh
I wonder what this guy's like on a date
I've decided you do need a father so I'm
gonna keep you
and I'm gonna teach you oh
[Music]
okay ah
wow goodness no
I thought you already knew
the fighting is a part I like the most
oh
God damn it there's no fear in love oh
as many times as it takes yes
laughs yup yup yup yup
yes
yes get your catharsis girl take that ax
and get the hell out of there how many
swags was that too jeez not enough
that's probably just mush oh no the ax
you guys know how I feel about weapons
being left behind take the freaking ax
or fashion yourself a new one oh thank
God
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh okay
it's okay baby girl oh
look at you
oh
oh wow wow
[Music]
that somebody in these episodes and with
them walking off into the business
all right
oh okay
I need a
I need a breather
oh
well yeah that was a hilarious and
heartwarming episode
that gave me faith in the future of
humanity what you think Tara what'd you
think of uh episode eight
oh okay
oh man yeah
um
well I'll just say the first thought I
mean that's so sweet the end it made me
cry but I like that
my assumption was Joel is gonna pop in
and save her and I like that she we have
now just seen how much she has learned
from Joel and just how strong she is as
a human that she didn't need it she
saved herself and Joel was there
obviously to take her at the end which
was nice but um I like that we didn't I
mean of course he killed those guys
before and then got to her but I'm just
saying at the end I really liked how she
did The Killing yeah yeah and then it
wasn't like Joel coming in and shooting
that guy I'm like no I hope you die by
her ax in her hands yeah totally 100
and I do quickly want to shout out Troy
Baker because yeah that in the moment uh
I'm sure the comments have filled up
already and I appreciate you guys for
for hipping us because yeah I wouldn't
have picked it up in the moment in fact
this experience Greg sent me like a
potential thumb for his reaction with
Andrew and he was like do you recognize
this actor and I was like well that's
buddy boy it's James but uh I I don't
know who the actor is and then it's
slowly like an echo started to come back
to me and then he was like it's Troy
Baker and I was like oh
oh so you know he must have greater
importance and sure enough you know
there's your voice of Joel right there
which is really cool given what uh the
you know dynamics of the episode had him
ultimately have to do in certain
contexts that's a name I have become
aware of over the years due to various
animated projects and especially going
through the DC animated stuff with koi
recently I've seen his name pop up a lot
there as he's been Batman and Joker and
various other characters and yeah just
the way that they have shown love to
those actors who helped bring these
iconic characters that people love so
much from the game to life and giving
them roles I mean especially him you
know the guy who played Tommy was a
little more of a side character but
especially Troy Baker here I thought
left a real big impression and did a
great job you know with just the tension
and the conflict within that character
of James
um and alongside Scott Shepard too uh as
David really great back and forth and
just that sense of History they have
with each other I haven't done a ton of
excess reading into parallels with the
game and and you know diving too deep
into any number of details that could
lead to spoilers and whatever else you
want to keep these fresh so yeah you can
Enlighten us to any other pertinent info
about him as it pertains to The Last of
Us in the comments but I did want to
make sure we at least touched on that
because uh yeah in the moment and and we
were talking during the credits and
stuff like that so I just didn't catch
it and uh and yeah now I will not forget
Troy Baker's face but uh but this is the
experience that taught it to me so so
yeah thanks for helping us though or
roasting us or both back to the review
it's fascinating because
they give you so many things to be
suspicious of that do kind of ultimately
come true but I I liked yeah the way
they drew this impossible seeming
scenario and then found their way out of
it
it like you said in that way where it is
her doing most of the heavy lifting for
herself and it's like yeah Joel is able
to you know get back up on his feet but
he's not just like full adrenaline you
know kicking ass and just moving like
it's nothing and like if there's one
thing I did wonder about and they do it
I think a fine enough job in the
dialogue of basically addressing that
yeah like most of these people who live
here they're not violent they need
somebody to lead them they're probably
very scared and so even though part of
me was like where is everybody doing all
of this yeah uh having you know the
pastor and Buddy Boy uh David and James
I think their names were having them as
your sort of main forces uh in the camp
and then having all those other guys out
looking for Joel and everything like
that like it seemed at least
geographically like okay they put all
their kind of uh fight and ready people
on both of these sides of this Mission
so so geographically that made sense but
yeah just having this debate and having
this unfolding of this guy's character I
thought was really fascinating whoever
that actor is uh who played what is his
name I think it was David uh he just did
such a great job and it's he endears or
at least me he endeared me and I thought
they did a great sort of representation
of the peeling back of the layers
because at first you're like okay I see
how we're on two sides of a conflict and
while we probably can't fully make this
amicable you don't seem like that bad of
a guy and I get the position that you're
in
but sure enough the deeper you get into
the episode and the more desperate
circumstances become for him in
particular you start to see all the
layers peeled back and yeah like this is
you know like the worst guy
oh and it's funny like I'm curious to
know what people think because on the
one hand like you know he's presented as
a religious leader and so part of you is
like okay it had to go down this route I
guess not only is he
yeah you know more of a cult leader in
this here and now than he is truly like
a pastor or a savior even though he
comes across very much that way but then
yeah he's got the violence and he's also
got the
you know inappropriate
urges like that whole scene I thought
was great in the cage for multiple
reasons but partly it just becomes so
uncomfortable when you're like I can't
tell if this is just a trust building
thing or if he really is implying like
no you'll be my girl wife and we will
lead this together with you
subtle grooming yeah and it's like ah
like it's I thought they earned it
really well because on the one hand you
know you I I think that's a place that
you would naturally if you want to make
a twisted Pastor character I feel like
that's one of the places you directly go
um but I thought the way they portrayed
it and the way that actor portrayed it
um just lent a lot of credence to it it
was really engrossing
that like especially because you
couldn't tell when he's like we don't
kill like that girl who's like kill him
and then he's like like killing's wrong
but really
when you think back on it when he's like
alive you're like oh because you want to
keep her for yourself probably yeah you
want somebody who isn't already
entangled with the rest of the game the
rest of the group develop this new
Dynamic with you can lock her in a cage
do some slight grooming yeah
yeah the eater if it doesn't sort of
right which which that too I I loved the
way they I love the way they used and
didn't use Music throughout this because
when they have that
first like dinner scene where everyone's
just chowing down and all the sounds of
of Cutlery and eating
and you're just sitting here in this
situation you're again I think designed
to think there's got to be people in
there if they're having a food scarcity
there has to be some kind of Donner
Party parallel you know we gotta eat
people and uh and I love the way they
held on to that until the very end and
then Ellie sees the because you know
she's in the cage and just the visual
cues let you in on the idea of like
good kind of kitchen any room for to
have this cage yeah and then you see the
ear and all that and uh and I like the
way they handled that too it's like it's
one of those conclusions that I think is
pretty easy to get to in a scenario like
this but I thought they represented it
with a lot of credence to make it
believable and not feel contrived yeah
it also came off very culty in the
episode when they bring in the the deer
or the elk or whatever it was it was a
deer right whatever they bring it in and
everyone is so venison everyone is so
silent it's so not it is just him
talking and leading in the beginning one
person says a thing and he is like
absolutely not having it and then when
they bring it you you assume that they
would be excited or happy and that's
when you really know like Uh something's
like off here something yeah this whole
place like if you talk you're probably
yeah exactly and like he smacks that
girl upside the face and everybody seems
very sort of nobody stands up like there
are dudes in that room Not Just Women
and Children right there's other guys
there that could be like yo man like we
shouldn't be doing this and I'm like oh
does that mean that you and your lackeys
they all have guns and nobody else does
and you're lackeys will like shoot
anybody who stands up to you because
like now we're talking like church Mafia
sure no and it makes you wonder like it
gives you a lot to them think about like
yeah is this guy taking in people who
are just docile and only the ones who
are inclined to believe him like do
accidents befall or do they you know
take out people who just aren't with you
know their version of the program or or
his version of how this is supposed to
go and uh and to his whole story about
like I love that that flip of the
inspiration of like I found God after
the apocalypse and then realizing later
on that no you probably didn't you just
probably were somebody in your previous
Life as a teacher or whatever a math
teacher or whatever he was who probably
you know felt beholden to so many
systems and probably felt very small and
now you've found he says that whole
thing about you're like me you're a
leader you know you you know what people
need and you know how to you know
persuade and protect people and all that
stuff and and he talks about like I got
these people to look out for they love
me you know they look up to me and you
could tell he probably you know has
lived a life where he would have always
wanted that level of status and Grandeur
and now he's finally able to achieve it
and also feed his worst inclinations
along the way
yeah I feel like he's also smart enough
to go what's the biggest Ploy I can use
to gather a group of people and make
them feel safe sure religion Bible let's
just like become this thing that most
people are like in when you're close to
death most people like I didn't press
started praying right you're like I was
in a plane crash it's going down you're
like say in your prayers so it's it's
like oh yeah he's probably smart enough
to use that as his Ploy yeah yeah
totally I found God no you you just
became a God yeah uh but but yeah like
so many great like so many great
characterizations that I think really
help the the tropier aspects of you know
the things there are nuts and bolts of
what happens here that we've seen before
but I thought that they really well
realized both the character sides of
that and just the geography again like
the way that they split the two groups
up and they've got you know these guys
hunting Joel and them taking Ellie back
like they really draw this impossible
feeling situation and then when Ellie
you know the escalation of Ellie making
these moves against these people and
sort of never relenting on her instincts
of distrust for them uh like when she
finally has him cornered and she's just
beating him with that Cleaver like you
really feel all that rage and pain and
anguish come out both for this situation
but probably just all of what's been
pent up up until now you know and and
for as much as Ellie has been sort of uh
carefully guided and handled in terms of
like weapons and when and how to use
them like this was just full-on just
like let it all out girl
and I really felt for her in those
moments and and then when Joel comes
back at the very end like I think we
both got got teary-eyed because you just
feel the sort of
desperate
relief that it's like a very specific
life moment that I feel like most
everybody has at some point but they're
rare that's sort of like I am just
overcome right now and I'm not even
fully aware of my surroundings and then
you sort of Clap into somebody close a
warm you know comforting figure and then
in a different way it all comes out then
then the you know then the vulnerability
you know overflows rather than the rage
yeah and uh and I thought that was kind
of beautifully handled there yeah I mean
up until that point she Ellie was always
just a strong snarky smart girl who
could handle herself and dealt with the
independence of Joel and she had that
same Independence but at that moment she
was just a little girl yeah needed Joel
in that moment and you know he is now
like her actual father figure right he
he is now a foundation for her like a
rock and he has always been there and in
that moment it was like you just saw
Ellie is like oh she's a kid but we've
we haven't seen that I don't even think
from the top I think it's like now in
episode eight we've seen her in that
moment just in that moment after that
you're like she's a kid you know and she
needed she needed like a hug from uh uh
like a family member because Joel is
like family now whether they say it out
loud or not and I think that's why I
found it so touching you just finally go
oh yeah Ellie's a badass but like she's
still a kid
sure and like that's a great point
because especially in this episode so
much of it is like the exact opposite
like my my companion my parental figure
my friend
is completely out of commission I gotta
figure out everything I gotta hold up
these guys and make sure I get out of
this situation I gotta find us some food
I gotta find us medicine I gotta figure
out where and how to administer the
medicine all on my own and then yeah get
put in the cage almost eaten it's like
it's it's way more than anybody should
ever have to deal with but that also on
the heels of everything else you know
it's like even in the mall with Riley
she's not fully abled there there are
moments and glimpses where they get to
forget about things and just have fun
and be kids but this was a different
version this was yeah like the most
vulnerable the just I need a hug please
consult me this is too much to handle
right yeah yeah
yeah and uh and two I mean I love I love
the way they've geographed the time too
because you know you've got Joel
basically on his back for since two
episodes ago through the last episode up
until here and so they made like a
really nice gradual uh just you know re
just getting him back on his feet was a
nice gradual process that I thought was
pretty tangible and then when he's got
those two guys it's like yeah Joel seems
better equipped in these situations than
these guys probably are despite the fact
that they are in perfectly good health
so even there I was pretty pretty easily
able to suspend that disbelief and then
he's got that guy with the knife and
he's like point on the map and he does
the kind of the same thing as he did
with the couple from a few episodes ago
the the Native American couple where
he's like you know you tell me where and
then you tell me where and if they don't
match and you know obviously it plays
out different here but uh I believe him
uh but yeah like really well designed
designed episode in terms of both what
it does for Joel and Ellie and as well
as getting a yet another glimpse into
what how certain people will respond
what life might be like you know in this
situation yeah because we thought before
like three episodes ago that I was like
oh the what are you called they weren't
the fireflies over that were they the
fire no in that group that I'm like
she's she's the cult leader they were
just a group that was weird they weren't
a cult this is a cult no in like an
apocalypse there's gonna be there's
gonna be some Cults and now we got to
one where they're eating people and he's
just like slapping anybody who talks
yeah he is clearly status one of this
cult yeah people like I love again the
way that they let you bounce off of
those things because at first you're
just like oh these people are just Meek
and and tired and cold but also probably
no they're also probably afraid to speak
up to this guy yeah like there's
probably a lot of like buried pushed
down fear amongst these people and so I
wonder how they're gonna fare now that
they don't have any of their
heavyweights I just find it so odd that
if I was in that group and obviously he
had to build trust to get their loyalty
meaning he couldn't be slapping him
around right away right so but then once
you see that he does do that and they're
like they're all just seemed so Meek I'm
like it's so crazy to me that they're
not holding a meeting to start a riot I
would like steal a weapon in the middle
of the night and just shoot him and all
of his buddy boys
uh and be like I'm gonna lead it now I'm
nice let's go get food like I I find it
so odd I know that it's proud it's very
difficult and you're afraid to lose your
life but I'm always like man you got it
come on now like start a riot and kill
the bad got the numbers yeah you have
the numbers you know and it makes you
like like this is one of those episodes
that gives you so many different
directions to wonder in because yeah
that I'm like what how much do these
people know about this guy and what is
WE peer in on what appears to be like
the average day here but yeah like you
could every time we visit a new pocket
you're like yeah there's a whole life
happening here you could do a whole show
just about this if you wanted to I mean
you know not that I'm saying that should
happen obviously the Joel and Ellie
story is part of the bread and butter
that holds this all together but there's
yeah just so much interesting potential
to these things and and you know the way
they realize this character like yeah he
is pretty villainous by the end
especially this whole like this is my
favorite part the struggle
but you know there are elements of the
character at times that aren't 100 that
and that's the interesting drama that
whole thing about like cordyceps isn't
evil cordyceps is just doing its natural
thing and it's just perpetuating itself
protecting its own it's it's you know
ensuring the longevity of its species
which you know is an interesting thing
to acknowledge because yeah it is just
sort of a force of nature that that
happens and I love the use of the bite
too and making us wonder about that
because I don't think we've ever had
that we have like where it's like
somebody right and do they become
infected yeah yeah I was like oh wait is
he going to like if we're with him long
enough is he going to turn because she
lives with that inside of her right
I don't know who knows yeah I hope he
doesn't because then he'd still be
around sure like I just just please let
him be oh and it's a cool counterweight
too because she does the thing with uh
uh what was the little boy Sam she she
tries to apply her blood as a cure and
then she tries to use it the opposite
direction here and I like that we don't
kind of have a full we don't know yeah
it's gonna yeah which direction that
goes in and it's you gotta be not that
easy either way right but he also I mean
if he turned into a butter lettuce head
he would just be it would be all falling
off I mean she chopped him up good she
chopped him up real good he would just
be he'd be salad really honestly he's
the chop sound yeah for sure he's a
chopped salad nobody wants to eat him
though even though they're they're used
to eating people oh thanks oh God yeah
not you buddy and the way they they
handled that I mean yeah you like you
know in that that dinner scene you're
able to hone in and be like I don't know
man yeah I don't know and then and then
when they reveal it they don't go
full boring to just like cannibal land
but it's enough it's like you see the
bodies hanging up in there clandestine
meat freezer and you see the the
someone's got to clean up the ears man
yeah somebody's gonna clean up the kill
floor oh gnarly but yeah this was this
was a really fascinating episode and
really well handled really interesting
drama Great Performances across the
board especially from I mean from Bella
Ramsey especially Pedro Pascal of course
but also the guest cast great use of
Music great use of atmosphere you really
feel the chill and the cold of
everything and and even the tension of
the fire at the end him kind of looking
him of like which which of these do I
focus on and do I just let this room
burn for my own selfish desire or do I
take care of the greater good arguably
and douse this fire and make it so that
we still have a dining hall to eat
people in I don't know this is one of
those episodes where I think you could
go on forever and ever talking about it
but uh but yeah this was this was great
Bravo and I cannot wait to see what the
finale holds because jeez yeah so I'm
sad yeah I don't want it to be over yeah
me neither R.I.P their horse
uh R.I.P that deer and uh and yeah you
got anything else before we hit the road
well guys leave a like leave a comment
with your thoughts on the episode uh are
you excited for the end of the season
are you sad that we'll have to wait uh
for another keeping helping of The Last
of Us leave any of your thoughts down
below that aren't spoilerific because
obviously you get the point and uh last
but not least let's let's do a pitch
Gabriel if this episode could have used
anything it was a guardian angel Gabriel
haha you see what I did there religious
episode religious shout out Gabriel
though I mean you are such a lovely and
kind Presence at our patreon you are the
pastor I would follow during the
apocalypse you know if you made some
kind of realization in your life you're
like you know what I need a flock I need
to extol my virtues to the people I
would be like yes please fill my brain I
don't want to think for myself anymore
I'm tired of doing that that's why I do
most days it's hard it's confusing just
tell me what to think Gabriel yeah um
the only thing I think I would say to
you is just to keep your pledge
indefinitely forever uh and uh otherwise
we will not follow absolutely not no
that's that's the price you know we
everybody has a price and this is ours
yeah so uh you know the may the Lord be
with you
and also with you and uh and also with
you is that how it goes I have to say it
back right everybody in church goes down
a chain and they're like also with you
also with you everybody by the end of
the ceremony or the service you know has
had all four hours yeah okay yeah that
takes up most of it yeah there's like a
couple scriptures a little bit of a
sermon we pass out the YouTubers but
mostly it's people shaking hands feeling
like also with the news
you don't want to leave anybody out
people pleasing a church okay I get it
anyway Gabriel thanks for joining us and
we'll catch you next month love you
buddy
foreign
[Music]